>>Eric Bidelman: All right.
Are we ready?
Android is processing my photo.
Hold on.
All right.
Guys, I really want to thank you for coming
to my session.
This is The Web Can Do That, in case you've
misplaced what session you should be in.
Apparently none of you want to get free Android
hardware downstairs, so I do really appreciate
your time for the next hour.
This is going to be adventures into HTML5.
Just so you know who you're talking to up
here, my name is Eric Bidelman and I work
on the Google Chrome team.
I'm an advocate for Chrome team, I teach developers
HTML5, help them use it by writing tutorials.
Of course, if you want to contact me there's
Google+, there's the Twitter and there's also
a blog that I don't write to very often, but
it does have some interesting things I think
on it.
So that's who is up on stage.
I get this a lot.
People are really skeptical about HTML5 still
and so they don't know what's possible.
And so part of my job is to come up here and
teach you guys and you too, the folks at home,
what is possible on the Web.
So today's talk is that the agenda is there's
going to be no agenda whatsoever.
So I'm going to sort of highlight really cool,
interesting use cases that HTML5 can now solve
that you probably didn't know were possible
on the Web today.
Things that you probably need to build a real
world application on the Web.
So a little bit of convention about this slide
deck.
This is a living, breathing slide deck.
I'm doing something a little bit different
with this.
You will see in the top right corner there's
a legend and there's a radar, and that signifies
that stuff is on the radar.
Keep it on your radar, it's still pretty new,
it's changing quickly.
I can actually make CORs requests, cross origin
resource requests, [indiscernible] XHRs, to
the WebKit issue tractor, which is really
nice.
So as soon as a bug is fixed, I know it's
fixed, I can mark them, denote it with this
little bug guy as it gets crossed off.
So you kind of know when you go back to this
slide at greater@html5.com.
It's not up right now.
I'll post it after the slides.
But there are spec links and you know the
stuff is up to date.
Okay.
So without further adieu let's jump into the
number one main awesome, sweet thing that
the Web can do.
The first is that we have CSS for Web apps.
And you're probably like whoa -- yeah, Mythbuster
style.
You're probably like, whoa, Eric, we've had
CSS for a long time.
What's up with that?
Well, we have.
We had a lot of great stuff in CSS.
We have floats and absolute positioning and
tables and all this stuff kind of working
together.
The real problem with that is it was all designed
in times of websites, not Web apps.
So if you want to do complex Web layout it's
really, really hard until now.
So I'm calling 2012 sort of the rise of CSS
for Web apps, and that's because the working
groups have proposed a number, a slew of new
stuff that we can play with eventually as
Web developers.
Regions for things like flowing and magazine
type layout and design.
Flexbox layout, which I will talk about, it's
one of my particular favorites, being able
to easily position things on the page in a
flexible manner.
Grid layouts and hierarchies in ASCII and
CSS so you can define where things show up
on a page.
It makes sense.
If you're building something on top of CSS
you need engines and different mechanisms
to do that for Web apps.
And then there's the bells and whistles, there's
the hierarchies, there's the folders and effects
and other really cool stuff coming down the
pipeline.
CSS variables.
If you guys attended the Web component session
earlier, that stuff is finally coming to CSS.
You can finally use variables in CSS.
It's not that exciting, but it's super exciting
as a Web developer that you don't have to
use a Web processor anymore.
So why am I picking on Flexbox out of all
this new stuff?
Flexbox is really great for Web layout design
and it's really going to solve and is solving
the sort of common use cases of a Web app.
So that Holy Grail layout, that header, that
footer, that three-column tiered system, very
hard to do with, notoriously hard to do with
CSS today.
Very easy with Flexbox.
And so the way Flexbox works is that there's
a new display property.
So I can tell a container to be a Flexbox
container and I'm doing also something in
this slide deck, nobody is going to catch
me on vendor prefixes.
I'm using sort of a compile type syntax, a
mix-in syntax to denote that any time you
see a + for CSS that means vendor prefixes
are involved.
I can tell, for instance, this right container
to be a Flexbox container with display vendor
prefix flex.
And we can do things like center content horizontally
and vertically super easy.
With three lines of CSS we can do this now.
We don't have to use negative margins or JavaScript.
So along my main access here -- this is a
little bit of Flexbox terminology.
In my cross origin access, I can justify content
to the center, I can flex it to the start,
I can say everything be adjusted far to the
right.
And I can also align those items in that cross
access, so I can align items to the center,
I can allow them to the bottom.
I can do things like stretch to take up the
available content of your parent container.
Very, very handy with layout.
And I can do also things like distribute yourself
evenly in a container.
Take up the available space and put an even
distribution of white space around yourself.
Another cool thing about Flexbox is that it
completely takes away the sort of mapping
of your source to how things are rendered
on the page.
So typically what happens is that you define
your A, your B and your C div.
These are just three divs inside of this flex
container.
And that's how I've weighted out my markups,
right?
I have an A, B and C in my markup.
But maybe I don't want to render A, B and
C in that order, and I can do that through
different properties of Flexbox.
I have this flex direction property, so again
vendor prefix.
So right now we're flexing in a row, but I
can choose to change the order of that row.
I can reverse the order of the row using row
reverse.
I can tell these items to be in a column so
A, B and C are not in a row now, but they
can be rendered in a column.
And then using the order property I can sort
of change the order depending on what value
I set here.
So by default these are all the same order
as they're laid out in markup, but I can tell
the second div to come before A. So this is
independent of how I've got my markup out,
just rendering it different next to the page
using the orientation and direction properties
of Flexbox.
I can also tell it to come after everything
as well.
But another really cool thing that Flexbox
solves is sort of this type of use case where
you have the same height columns.
So in order to do same height columns -- this
is a great example of floating three divs
across the page.
But if I want to do something like make these
even, right, I have a really awesome UI, I
can do that with a little bit of JavaScript
where I can set these and get the computed
style of the content and know exactly how
tall they should be.
But what happens if my UI is being rendered
through JSON, I'm porting in an RSS feed or
something, and -- my content is dynamic.
As soon as that happens, I put a little bit
more content, my columns are now out of sync,
I have to recalculate, I have to touch JavaScript,
I have to set properties in CSS.
It just feels super, super icky.
So the way Flexbox solves that is through
its bread and butter, flexibility.
So it's really nice.
I can tell things to take up the available
amount of the parent container.
In this case all of these items, A, B, and
C, are equally distributed in the Flexbox
container.
But I don't have to do that.
I can tell the second difference to be two
times greater, grow to be two times as big
as your siblings or three times as big or
four times as big.
I can also tell it to shrink.
So A and C will be equal size with a flex
property of one and then B is going to be
a negative flex property.
So it's really handy when it comes to that
Holy Grail layout.
So I want to show you an example of this.
This is a live page.
Think of this as that Holy Grail layout, that
header, footer, that three column in the center.
The first thing you will notice is this whole
thing, maybe not the resolution, but the whole
thing is centered vertically and horizontally
in my page with three lines of CSS, right,
the alignment and justification there.
Next thing to happen on this page is a really
sweet navigation bar.
You will notice that that last button up there
has more content than the rest of my buttons,
but that's okay.
We can tell the Flexbox items to grow and
shrink.
So all my buttons are exactly the same size.
I didn't set anything in CSS, particularly
the widths of those buttons, it's just flexing
to take up the available space of that complete
Web app.
But if I add more, all of these buttons will
continue to flex and be of equal weight and
size and distributed evenly.
It's great for navigation, it's great for
UI.
We can also use some CSS transitions on the
flex property so I can do really cool UI flex
here, little zippies here, so these are just
Flexbox items within a Flexbox container with
the column orientation.
And with the CSS hover I can tell them to
grow with the flex property to grow to be
two times or three times greater than rest.
My center content in the center of the article
content I can use transforms to do things
with vertical alignment there on the side,
my navigation on my side.
If I wanted to I could combine the media queries,
and you remember I could independently order
my source and how things are presented using
that order property.
So that combined media source may be in my
mobile UI.
I have something that is different.
If I scale this down to mobile UI, notice
in the case of my desktop, the article is
in the center.
That's my main content, that's what users
should be seeing, but when I scale on to mobile
maybe the articles should come before that
navigation element, that zippy on the side.
So I can do that with that ordering orientation
property, very handy when combined with media
queries.
So that's CSS Flexbox.
And that's the new one.
There is an older Flexbox if you've been following
this stuff closely.
That's actually available in a number of browsers
right now.
So WebKit, Chrome.
IE 10 will have the new Flexbox as well.
So you can expect to use this relatively soon.
All right.
Number two amazing thing is dynamic CSS.
By dynamic CSS I actually mean -- that was
confirmed too.
I actually mean the calc function.
If you attended the session earlier today
on Web components, they have CSS variables
coming.
But we actually have the ability to do similar
things now with the calc function.
It's been around in Firefox for a long time,
just came to WebKit very recently.
What I have here is a live example of something
that's in the Flexbox specification.
So I basically have a bunch of divs.
I have a div within a div within a div, and
I put a border radius of 50% on this div,
so that's what's creating the circles.
I've specified the parent circle container
to be 300 wide and 300 tall.
What's really nice about this is I can use
the CSS calc function, so again vendor prefix,
to calculate each of these inner divs to be
100% minus 4 EM.
Each of these children divs is 4 EM smaller
than its parent container and that's producing
sort of this target effect.
What's really neat about this is you combine
it with what we just talked about, which is
Flexbox, and so that's what's doing the alignment
of the center and justifying the content to
the center.
So that vertical center, that horizontal center
with three lines of CSS now, combined with
the calc function you can do something like
this, which you haven't been able to do before
without a little bit of JavaScript.
Really awesome.
This stuff now can work together really easily
with a lot of new CSS stuff.
And support is actually really good for this
as you can see by this slide.
So that's what's happening with CSS.
Number three amazing, awesome thing that the
Web can do is data binding.
And you're like what?
The web can't do data binding.
Oh, but it can.
This is actually old hat for JavaScript frameworks.
If you use your framework like Angular JS,
for example, one of my favorites at the moment,
data binding looks like this.
This is how they define a template in Angular.
It's just HTML, which is really, really nice.
I don't have to learn a new API or markup.
If I want to do one-way data binding I can
have an input, I can change the input, and
as I change that my template is being re-rendered.
I'm just re-rendering the value of the input
as it changes.
And that's done through sort of Angular's
magic.
My model in this case is this val.
That's what I'm calling the model.
And as I change the input, val is being re-rendered
to the template.
So that's one-way data binding use a JavaScript
framework.
But we can actually do a neat little trick
that I kind of discovered, which I'm calling
it poor man's data binding, and it's using
data attributes, HTML data attributes.
So we don't need a framework to do one-way
data binding.
So the way this works is that you have a data
attribute.
That's your data model.
That's where you're going to be storing your
values.
And then a lot of people don't know, but there's
this really awesome, amazing attribute that
you can use to pull out values from the DOM
and use those values in CSS.
So that's how we'll get the data from the
data model.
Then our view from this case, what we're rendering
this data to, is generated content.
So before and after pseudo elements and generating
that model to those elements.
And so we don't have a JavaScript framework
to work for us in this case so we have to
actually hook up Web event listeners to do
this and watch for the changes.
So what you get back with the poor man's data
binding is exactly the same thing.
So I can have an input, and as I change that
input, I can re-render that to my template,
my pseudo elements, on the fly.
So a small amount of code to do this.
I set up an event change event on my input.
And then as that input changes, the user changes
it, I'm sending a data attribute using the
data set object.
So data-values is my thing that I'm changing
to the new value.
And the really cool part of this is that I'm
using before and after pseudo selectors for
this.
So I'm using that attribute method to rip
out that data element, that data attribute,
from the DOM, dividing it by the max attribute,
in this case 100.
So you get the exact same thing as the Angular
JS case.
I don't need a framework to do the -- this
type of one-way data binding.
You can do the exact same thing with an extra
span or DOM node and just render the inner
text of that.
That's cool.
This is a little cooler in my opinion and
it illustrates that we can do this now in
HTML5.
But we can also use something better, which
is the dataless element, something new to
WebKit, and Opera has had this for a slew
of time.
This is sort of a semantic way to do one-way
data binding.
So in this case your data model is actually
defined in markup.
You have data list element, you can reference
it by an ID, so the browser's out, and each
option is sort of the values of this data
list.
And what we bind to in this case is an input
element, so we reference it by the list attribute
of ID and so we're finding this data list
-- these values to this input element.
So it's a great way to do things like auto
complete.
So I have an example of that in here.
I have the list of browsers.
When I click on this I get the values from
that data list.
We bound that data to this input.
If I do things like -- if I start typing,
just as you expect I have auto complete behavior.
That's super handy.
That's the HTML5 way to do one-way data binding.
You actually saw it in that blue column example,
you saw me use this data attribute trick as
well to render out the heights of those columns
as they were changing when I clicked on them.
And both of these methods for data binding
are actually all supported on all the bottom
browsers, which is really, really sweet.
But if you're doing something simple like
I just showed you, you can do one-way data
binding just with HTML, just on the Web.
How many people think HTML can access a file
system?
It's hard to see up here, we have some believers.
We have a lot of naysayers.
It's cool.
This one is totally confirmed.
It's confirmed because I got really excited
about this one.
I got so excited that I wrote a book.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Bidelman: Shameless plug, I know.
What we have now in HTML5 is a file system
API.
This is something that you can do very easily
in a native app.
You can read and write folders and persist
data.
That's very common.
We should be able to do this on the Web as
well and we can do that with the file system
API.
So there's a new property on the window method
called request file system, and this is vendor
prefixes alluded to by this underline here.
You can open the file system and read and
write files and folders.
That's really huge.
The security behind this is exactly like the
other offline storage API.
So it's on a per-origin basis.
You can't read and write to somebody else's
Web app and you certainly can't come out of
the browser and write to somebody's My Pictures
folder or the system's My Documents folder.
It's all on a per-origin for your Web app.
But it's super powerful.
And the real benefit of this is to get around
issues that something like App Cache does.
So if you've used App Cache, it's kind of
clunky, it's hard to use.
With the file system API we can easily and
dynamically cache individual files and folders
very quickly.
Store them in folders, arrange them in a hierarchy,
nuke that if we need to.
So as a quick example of caching an image
file, for instance, just a png file, we're
going to use a friend, XMLhtpp request, pull
that guy down, and we're not pulling it as
a streamer, but we're pulling it as an array
buffer, so we'll set the response type and
we're just going to get a raw byte array back
from that image.
And we get the response and we'll open the
file system using WebKit file request file
system, give it a store, so maybe we'll store
a megabyte worth of data in this.
We'll use the file system's root directory,
just the root entry of my file system, and
we'll call it image.png, we'll create it if
it doesn't exist using this param here.
We'll get back a file entry, we'll then write
that response of the XHR out to the file system
and save that data.
So this is just creating a file writer object.
We can set up events for when the write has
ended, if there's any errors that happened.
And the important part is this guy right here,
this writer.write.
We're gonna write out that data, the response
of the XHR, create a new blog from the response
and that's going to be saved.
The image is gonna be saved locally to our
Web app and we can use that as if it were
a local resource to our Web app.
So that's the final product.
You can see there's a lot of callbacks that
are involved here.
I have at least one, two, three, four -- four
to five levels of sort of callback -- callback
spaghetti that's happening here.
Callbacks are hard.
People don't like to deal with them.
This is a famous quote that I just said.
[Laughter]
>>Eric Bidelman: Actually, I wanted to make
it simpler for developers.
Again, I'm really passionate about this API.
It's very powerful.
So I wrote this library called filer.js.
You can check out the GitHub URL there.
But essentially what it is is a library that
wraps common UNIX commands on top of the file
system API calls.
So we have things like LS and CD and copy
and the things that you know from interface
that make it super easy to use this API.
If I want to copy a file, for instance, filer.copy,
the file path you want to copy to and then
renaming it as well.
So super handy.
It makes the whole thing much more approachable
if you're familiar with this sort of development.
Let's see a demo of this guy.
So this is called the file system API playground.
Essentially what this is is a Web app that
sits on top of the file system API.
So right now I don't have anything in this
guy, but you can easily use HTML5 Dragon drop
to add some files, boom, I can add some text
files.
I can open these files, right, so there's
this sort of notion of using this -- this
resource locally with referencing it via URL.
Can use that within my Web app.
Can also read this file and preview it if
I wanted to using the file reader API, and
get some metadata such as the date and last
modified times.
Can use filer.js and API to rename the file.
The best part about this is I've actually
cached these resources, so if I refresh this
page, my Web app, right, has those values
and those resources saved in them, so all
the changes I made are being persisted, which
is really awesome.
Can create files and folders.
Create a folder using the API.
You can drill into it.
Import some data here.
Luckily it's after lunch so, you guys don't
have to get too hungry.
But this is really great.
I mean, this is native stuff, but it's on
the Web.
We can write and read files and folders now
using the file system API.
So you're probably asking yourself this: This
is great, but if it's only in Chrome, like
why am I going to use it?
Then I'm like, oh, yeah.
So again, I really like this API, you guys,
so I decided to implement a polyfill stream
library that sits on top of index DB that
then you can use in your Web app to have basically
the file system API in browsers that support
index DB.
So same Web app, right?
Same Web app running in Chrome is running
in FireFox.
And I can add files and folders to this guy,
maybe -- it's a nightly build, so I don't
know -- there we go.
And if I refresh this up, those files that
I just wrote to the Web app are preserved.
So that library is called IDBfilesystem.js.
And if you're interested in this API, the
file system API, check it out, it basically
means that we can now use this API in a relatively
performant way in the browsers that do support
index DB.
Super Stoked about it.
Hope you guys get Stoked about it, too.
Files and folders, the Web can do that.
All right, Number 5.
This one looks suspicious.
Totally is busted.
Just making sure you guys are paying attention.
[ Laughter ]
>>Eric Bidleman: The real Number 5 is serverless
downloads.
So we got data in the file system, we're storing
data in our Web app -- where is my clicker?
What happens when you want to get data back
out of your Web app, right?
So for a long time, if you wanted to download
a file and trick the browser into downloading
a file from the response of your server, you
would have had to do something like this:
You would send a content disposition header
as an attachment, give it a file name, and
essentially what this did was when the browser
hit this response, the browser would sort
of -- it would trick it into downloading a
file and it would invoke the browser's download
manager.
What we have now is a lot of people are writing
thick clients, right?
Maybe there's no server involved whatsoever,
so how do you do this?
How do you send a header if you don't have
a server?
It's impossible.
So smart folks in the Web community were like,
hey, we can solve this, we've got this great
idea, let's make an attribute, we'll call
it "download".
That makes a lot of sense.
And what download does is you can use with
an anchor tag for instance, and so what happens
is -- normally what happens is if you -- if
a user clicks on this H ref to this logo.png,
what happens is the browser will open that
image in a new tab and you can view the image.
That's cool.
But what happens if you have download specified,
this attribute, and you can give it the name
of the file you want to download as, is that
it's going to trick the browser into doing
the exact same thing as the content disposition
header, and then you can download that file
instead of navigating to that resource.
So if none of that makes any sense to you,
I have an epic novel creator here, and this
is just a text area that I'm typing into,
so let me bring this up a little bit.
So just to show you that I'm typing live.
I'm just typing in this.
I'm composing my epic novel.
And then I want to have the user save what
they've just done, so I can do that using
the download attribute.
When I click this button, I'm going to create
a txt file, a text file in JavaScript using
the block builder API.
Create a dynamic link in JavaScript.
Attach that download attribute as my file
.txt as its value.
When I click that, the browser is not going
to open that resource, it's actually going
to download the file that I just created in
JavaScript, and if I open this, it's going
to be native to my system, and as you can
see, the text content that I just pulled out
from that text area has been saved.
I've just downloaded a file in JavaScript,
all clientside, no servers.
That's pretty sweet.
So we have the ability to save data in the
file system, we have the ability to get it
back out using the down attribute.
What about getting data in between apps?
Now, there's this thing called Web intense,
and I encourage you to go to Paul Kinlan and
James' session later in the week.
But one way to officially transfer data is
rocketships, of course.
But another way is with post message.
And in order to describe this and set this
up for you guys, I want to take you down sort
of memory lane of post message.
Post message started off as a way to communicate
with a Webworker or a window object, right?
You could send a string.
You could send "hello world" to a worker,
and then it could, I don't know, do something
interesting with that.
But what happened is, hey, people are gonna
-- the browsers are like -- developers got
smart, they were like let's just send JSON
stringify data.
So they'd stringify some JSON, and pass some
commands in and out of worker or to a window
object.
So it was totally cool, but then the browsers
were like, hey, like, we can do better, let's
just do that for them, just not have the ability
to stringify JSON, but let's just do it under
the hood, so what happens is the browser would
JSON stringify and JSON parse this message
out, so that was cool.
That got us one step further.
Sort of this post message evolution, but then
the third step that came along was the ability
to send more complex data, right?
You just saw me send a file -- create a file
in JavaScript.
Why can't I send a file into a Web worker
and do something interesting with it, or a
Web GL texter as an array buffer?
All right, we have binary data in -- on the
Web now; we should be able to do interesting
things with it.
So eventually , the browser is like, hey,
we'll open this up, we're going to use this
structured cloning algorithm to pass a blob,
a file into the Web worker and process it.
Or you can send an array buffer, so this is
really, really cool, right?
And a lot of the modern browsers support this.
You can send a massive, you know, data set
into a Web worker.
Do some computation on it in this sort of
multi-thread environment and then get it back
out and do something interesting.
So the real problem with this, though, is
that these are all -- all the methods I just
covered are copies, so that becomes very inefficient
when you're copying and sending amounts of
data in and out of a Web worker.
It's kind of pointless to have this awesome,
you know, multi-threaded Web worker doing
its thing, but if you can't get data in and
out very quickly, then it defeats the purpose.
So of course I wouldn't be up here if we can't
do better, and we can do better, and that
comes via transferable objects.
Transferable objects are something that the
Web GL community thought up because they need
this ability to do processing on large amounts
of data.
And so you can see this guy is using your
old friend, but it has different semantics,
and that's why this method is prefixed with
WebKit post message.
This is something that is supported in Chrome.
So what happens with the new post message
is that it's a zero copy, so if you're familiar
with like C++ or C, think of it as a pass-by
reference rather than a pass-by value.
And so the ownership of this data is actually
transferred from your main app to the worker
or window context that you're posting to.
And so what happens is that this becomes actually
really, really efficient, up to 50 times faster.
I measured this in Chrome 17.
So Chrome 17, you know, that is sort of long
gone now, but it could even be faster.
I don't know.
But the important point of this graph are
these last two columns here.
In Chrome 17 the difference between the regular
post message, which is on the left, the middle
one, and the right, is orders and orders of
magnitude.
This is a logarithmic scale, keep in mind.
Faster.
So basically what I did in this test was I
sent a 32 megabyte file into a Web worker.
I didn't do any processing on that file, and
then I sent it right back just to see how
fast that was.
I measured that.
And you can see the rate -- the round trip
simulated rate of that is super, super fast.
So this is really sweet for things like physics
simulations and again Web GL, gaming.
I have an example of this, and unfortunately
this is not super sexy to demo, but this is
my awesome sexy demo for transferable object.
This page has basically set up a Web worker.
I got a worker ready to be post messaged to,
and when I hit this run button, it's going
to use that new WebKit post message to send
data into Web worker.
I think we're sending -- we're sending a 32
megabyte array buffer, so this 32 megabyte
file into a web worker, and then sending that
right back, seeing how fast that is.
So I'll hit this, ready?
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
6 milliseconds.
5,000 megabytes a second simulated rate, right?
I mean, that is kind of ridiculous, right?
That's awesome.
That's awesome for sending large amounts of
data.
And that's a lot of data.
32 megabytes is no joke.
Pop up a full screen here.
Just to show you the difference -- I'm not
picking on any browser in particular -- but
a browser that doesn't support transferable
object, you can actually noticeably see the
difference here.
Let me zoom in.
So when I hit this, run, boom, boom.
So, not only do the numbers speak for themselves,
157 as opposed to 5,000 megabytes a second,
you can actually see the delay, right, visually
the delay that it takes for this Web app to
make that round trip request.
So significant difference using transferable
objects and performance.
In my opinion this is something that, you
know, the Web path form and workers in window
and post message should have had available
in the first place, but this is sort of a
common thing in the Web, right?
We're sort of incrementally improving on what
we already had, making it better and better
and better every time.
This one's only in Chrome, again something
that should be in every browser.
Efficiency is something we love in the Web.
How many people think the Web can access native
hardware?
Not using phone gap or something like that?
Okay.
Got some believers.
I love it.
You guys know this is when it's going to be
confirmed.
It's confirmed.
It's totally confirmed.
What I mean by accessing hardware is device
APIs.
There's a whole working group dedicated to
figuring this stuff out now.
And what I mean by devices are things like
geolocation and accessing the accelerometer
of this laptop, using web GL to access the
GPU, right, the graphics processor unit of
the laptop, using a very high level JavaScript
API.
I just showed you the file system API.
We can read and write folders and files on
the Web now.
Whether I'm online or offline, network connectivity,
all via JavaScript, battery API, game pad
API, all super possible.
Web RTC and Web audio, I want to briefly mention
on.
There's two dedicated sessions to these two
topics, because they're very -- they're noteworthy
and very complex and they should have a dedicated
session.
Being able to access voice and video on the
Web is sort of this coveted grail, right?
I mean, we've wanted to access the microphone
for a long time or get camera for a long time,
but you've needed a plug in to do this, so
this is one example of being able to sort
of -- the first step along this path to do
that, with one attribute, this x WebKit speech
attribute, we can annotate an input, and the
browser is going to annotate it with this
little microphone input.
Instead of typing in this Web app, it can
actually interact with the microphone in this
Web app.
"I want some coffee".
All right.
It worked.
Sometimes it doesn't.
Or you get some weird rendition.
But this is really great.
A different way to interact with my Web app.
I don't have much of an API to play with,
right?
It's sort of happening under the hood.
But I'm accessing the microphone of this laptop
using one attribute.
So what we have now is something way better.
We have camera and microphone access via Get
User Media.
Get User Media is coming out of the Web RTC
project, navigator dot -- either Get User
Media or the prefix version.
Also Christian from FireFox tells me this
is coming to FireFox and nightly builds, so
that should be on there as well.
To the camera, the device and the microphone
device.
With this call, I can specify that I want
audio access, I want video access, and what
I'm going to get back is a stream object representing
that data that I get from both devices.
And then what's really cool is again I'm using
different parts of the platform that have
already existed for a long time.
I'm using a video element.
HTML video is one of the core features of
HTML5 when it first came out.
Instead of setting the video source to, you
know, a movie file or an OVG file, I'm setting
it to a blob URL created from the data I get
from the camera.
So instead of a file, I'm just sending the
camera data and the microphone data directly
into this video tag, so that's what's going
to give us the ability to render live to video
tag.
So a little demo.
There's a lot of really cool demos people
created using Get User Media and the ability
to access the camera.
This is my demo.
I do trust this app.
I made it.
I wrote it.
So I'm gonna -- I can't see at the top.
I'm going to allow access.
We'll create a video element in JavaScript,
and there we go.
My first stage -- you can see behind -- so
this is great, no plug-ins, right?
This is just JavaScript on the Web, but again
I can combine this with different parts of
the Web platform, so I can use CSS filters
in real time to overlay this video with effects
like gray scale.
How about a blur effect in real time?
That's pretty -- that is pretty trippy.
Version effects, right?
Just using CSS, applying to this video, I
can do all that and still really awesome,
looks great.
I can combine it with a canvas, right, do
a photo booth effect.
[chuckling]
>>Eric Bidleman: All right.
That's enough of that.
One of my favorites, though, is this one called
the Web cam toy, so I'll grant access to this.
Okay, that uses my camera.
This is not going to use CSS filters, but
it's going to use the power of camera, the
power of Web GL, right?
So with Web GL we can access the GPU, that
native access, and we can do things -- really
awesome things with shaders.
Shader technology is amazing.
Again, this is all JavaScript using Web GL.
No plug-ins.
Look how fast it is.
Really trippy things.
Let me get to the cool stuff.
There it is.
[chuckling]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Eric Bidleman: Yeah.
This one is cool.
Super trippy.
Oh, yeah, 3D.
This is after you've had a few drinks at the
party tonight.
Just amazing things.
People have done thing with augmented reality,
right, holding up a paper -- piece of paper
with a QR code on it, the camera tracks you.
So play around with those.
When I put the slide up later, just really
awesome, amazing things.
Support for this is actually really good.
Opera just released Opera 12; it has this.
They've had it in the mobile version for a
long time.
It's coming to FireFox nightly I'm told, and
Chrome just released a stable version with
Get User Media, so we can do camera access,
we can do microphone access without a plug-in
now.
HTML5 audio has had a little bit of a slack
-- been problematic, to say the least.
But what we can do now with the Web audio,
guys, make it -- make it sexy again.
So HTML5 audio is great.
It's just like video, right?
Without a plug-in, we can play audio on the
Web, just populate a source attribute of an
audio tag.
Play it, that's cool, we don't need a plug-in,
but what if you want to do something like
this.
[Music Playing]
What if you want to visualize that data in
real time, get the frequency analysis as it
plays?
Visualize that on two canvas tags, plus Web
GL transforms a little bit of a reflection
on the bottom there.
Can't do that with HTML5 audio.
What we have now is ability to tie in to what's
called a Web audio API, tie in an audio tag
as a source to that API, so instead of driving
the Web audio API, via, you know, an XHR request
or something, we can just send data directly
to it -- sorry -- via -- via this audio tag,
so it's really, really important.
This doesn't have to just be a video.
It could be a -- excuse me, an audio tag,
it could be a video tag, so imagine I had
a HTML5 video playing, and that is the source
to the Web audio API, then you're visualizing
sort of effects, as movie changes and dark
monsters pop out, you can really scare people.
But the way the search works is really easy,
so we have the Web audio guy.
I encourage you to go to Chris Wilson's session
later in the week about this, really amazing
API.
A lot of low level access to the core audio
of the system.
High level JavaScript API on top of it.
Create an audio context.
Notifications -- I will create HTML5 audio
element, I will populate it with MP3 as its
source, set up a couple of controls, some
auto play on it.
The important integration point between these
two, sort of the old audio working with the
new Web audio, the capabilities of that API
is this create element source, media element
source.
That's how the audio tag is sort of filtered
and piped into the Web audio API.
Which leads us conveniently into Number 10.
So I get this one a lot.
A lot of people ask: "Hey, how come HTML5
can't do, you know, streaming audio?
Or streaming media?"
And it actually can.
It can do that through another old friend,
WebSockets.
So WebSockets have been around for a while.
It sort of suffered from the same limitation
of Webworker, where you can only send just
basic data.
It can send string data.
That's not so handy, right?
We have things like files and array buffers
and ability to use complex data.
We should be able to send and stream multi-media
or files to our web apps.
So we can do that now with WebSockets.
And WebSockets has a new sort of socket, that
binary type is the property you set on this.
And you set it to a blob or you set it to
an array buffer, and that tells the WebSocket
that's going to be speaking binary data instead
of just regular string data.
What's awesome about this is on my on message
event, I can use that directly to set an image
source, for instance, from a blog URL.
Instead of having to base 64 encode data on
either end, decode it, which is, you know,
the overhead associated with that, we can
just use the data directly that we get back.
So I have a couple of demos of this.
The first is a Chrome extension.
So I have a little Chrome extension installed
here and top right corner.
I'm going to click this guy.
Imagine this is my viewer.
I'm going to basically do a sort of screen
cast from the Web.
This is my viewer, imagine this is somewhere
around the globe.
I'm going to open a new window, pretend that's
here.
So when I click this guy again, it's going
to fire up a Websocket, binary Websocket,
and use the Chrome extension, screen capture
API to capture the current tab.
Google.com.
Sports, because sports is great.
So on the right side, I have my presenter,
this is just capturing the current tab as
a png as I scroll.
It's sending that data through a WebSocket
to the remote party.
You can see it's very performant.
I don't have to do any basic 64 encoding.
As I'm scrolling on the right on the live
page, that image is just being sent across
the wire in near real-time using the WebSocket.
That's really, really sweet, right?
We can do this now thanks to the Chrome extension
API, yes, but also via a binary WebSocket.
Whoa, inception.
[Laughter].
>>Eric Bidelman: We can also do other things
with different types of media.
So I just showed you a little teaser preview
of the Web audio API.
The API allows you to analyze sound in real-time
as it plays.
What I have here is a page that sets up a
binary WebSocket, and it's going to use the
file reader API to essentially cut an MP3
file up into multiple smaller chunks and then
it's going to connect to that WebSocket, send
each of those chunks across the wire, on my
-- on my left side here, the viewer side,
I'm going to use the Web audio API to schedule
those chunks at very precise times exactly
when they should happen.
So essentially I reconstruct the audio on
the other end and just sort of use the sequence
that it should be in and then visualize that
using the Web audio API.
I'm going to load up an MP3 file here on my
DJ machine, this guy in the right corner.
Binary WebSocket, web audio API.
No sound?
There we go, there's sound.
[ Music ]
>>Eric Bidelman: So again, streaming from
one client, streaming audio data using a WebSocket,
using the Web to reconstruct it and then visualizing
in real-time.
You can see the chunks coming in, I'm receiving
sort of mini chunks of that MP3 file as I
reconstruct the audio and sort of the current
time is playing.
Just to prove to you this is streaming, I
refresh this, come back at the exact same
spot.
It's using two brand new search capabilities
on the Web platform together, something that
you probably maybe not hopefully didn't think
was possible, in streaming audio on the Web.
No more plug-ins for this, you can do is now
using the Web platform.
[ Music ]
So that was really quick.
I covered a lot.
I just want to point out that we did cover,
you know, sort of everything under the sun.
The Web can do really amazing things, I hope
you do agree.
CSS, whether it's the new CSS stuff for Web
application layout and design, doing data
binding, doing things like file access, accessing
the native hardware, using -- officially transferring
data once you have it in your Web app, and
then doing really awesome things with some
of the older capabilities of HTML5 multi-media,
and also some of the newer stuff, combine
those two with the integration points.
Just want to point out, we have a Google+
developers page.
If you guys want to know more about what Chrome
is doing with HTML5, and the open web, check
that out.
If you are not using Chrome Canary, or the
developer channel, Chrome really does heart
HTML5.
A lot of this stuff I just showed you again
is very new.
So play with the new Chrome file bugs on new.crbug.com.
Let us know what you think.
Give us the feedback.
This presentation will be up on my GitHub
account at HTML5can, as soon as I exit this
stage.
You can also access these slides at HTMLfive,
with the five spelled out, can.com.
There's my social stuff if you want to follow
or Tweet at me.
I'm happy to take questions here and I will
also be available after the show, as well
as office hours tomorrow.
Thanks, guys, appreciate your time.
[ Applause ]